what is the end State the goal for what
we that we want this child to be don't
want them to be a consumer oh fine set
in the public school do I want them to
be a lemming to to be able to
um look at a book and go and do the
thing that the book tells me to do of
course and then public school I don't
have a use for that whether it's in the
military as a professional athlete or
now as an entrepreneur there's there's
no point where I look at that product
and I say
that's what I need that's that's the
role that I need to have filled what I
don't need somebody that is gonna
not build I don't need somebody that's
not going to innovate I don't need
somebody that's that only can consume
you know like that can that that knows
how to swipe I don't need that you know
I need somebody that can beautifully
critically think and imagine how to
solve a problem so if that's our end
State a critical thinker that is a free
thinker that can innovate build and
create well then let's go then now let's
answer your question is it what part
should they start learning the moment
they come out of the womb I promise
they're learning the amount that they
understand shame on us like we're not
even medically scientifically in a
position to understand how they are
learning but we just know that they are
you're right it's those first six years
they I mean I interviewed Bruce Lipton
and people like that that you know dive
into epigenetics and everything and then
up until about six years old that's when
the subconscious gets programmed that
person that subconscious that's kind of
who they're they're being is as an
entity right now at six they kind of
know who they are they're in their own
skin they're don't know their frontal
lobe is not built they do they cannot
make like big decisions about you know
permanently all life-altering decisions
they should not be making until you know
into their early 20s mid-20s still at
this point they now are like okay I want
to know things you know like I want to
learn how to read I want to understand
you know why the boy the little
lightning bolt on his head lived and
what does it mean for the future of you
know this school and that's where the
magic of learning starts happening is
because they want to it's intrinsic in
them to want to explore and to want to
go wow and to want to challenge and to
can I jump off this thing can um is it
going to hurt if I do I don't know maybe
that might be too too too tall how do
you create a critical thinker I think
the first thing that you have to do is
is show them how to make decisions
that's something that's taken from them
in the school system
I want our Learners to make all the
decisions for themselves and they have
to learn the consequence of those
decisions they are making all the
decisions where they're going to sit
when they're going to eat when they're
gonna drink what tools they're going to
use to help solve the problems is that
formula going to work there's a guide in
there and I'm using these these words so
people are tracking like a guide is like
a teacher but under the socratic
approach a guide isn't teaching a guide
is guiding and those those subtle
differences matter and so instead of
saying hey Tommy you did two plus four
wrong you said you you walk up and
you're like Tommy there should always be
a question Tommy is two plus four five
and that little difference asks him to
make then yeah another decision to look
at his own question and be like I think
it is is it not well if we have two
apples and I take two more apples how
many apples do we have but it's four
apples well Tommy you wrote that there's
five apples on there why did you write
five if and then yet again I'm asking
another question he's having to
critically think so you're conditioning
the mind to learn how to make lots of
little decisions the first thing that we
talked about if you're going to be able
to make those big decisions you have to
be faithful in those small ones and it's
no different so it's no different with
the mind you have to condition them to
make millions of little decisions in the
day good decisions like if you did not
do your homework and now it's time to go
outside and play it was your choice not
to do the thing when the time was for us
to do it and you chose to go and draw
something instead well we only have 45
minutes on the play gym in this 90
minute period you missed that time the
consequences you don't get to spend that
you still have to finish the volume of
work choices and consequences that's
right and those are taken from them and
it's it's it's heartbreaking how hard
should should we be on kids all I know
is when I play Monopoly or when I play a
game with a kid I just want to win like
I mean I'm not going to be uh I'm not I
want to win period like I laugh about
I'm like no no I'm gonna beat a
seven-year-old at Monopoly I don't care
you should absolutely beat a
seven-year-old at Monopoly
um that is his time to be learning about
how to play Monopoly because if he win
every time he will never get better at
Monopoly and then 20 years or 10 years
from now when he's 17 and he goes as a
senior to some camp and everybody's
playing Monopoly better than him and
he's super humiliated and then he goes
in like start your shotgun because he
can't win at everything because the
whole entire time you've been getting
him participation trophies and you've
been letting him win a monopoly and he
thinks he's as good at basketball he's
playing with a bunch of losers that
don't know how to play basketball no you
are setting him up for failure at
everything in life because you keep
handing him things to be successful at
let him struggle and fail it's the only
way you can take the first time my dad
saw a partition participation trophy he
like looked at it
was it a blue ribbon I know it was like
it was I mean it was gold is this like
it's like a gold medal uh so Socrates
the Socratic method right
um we're we're talking way way way older
than any form of this current experiment
that we call Public School the the
highest Learners ever were not educated
in a public school
um they sat in a circle still quoting
him yeah so from marker Marcus Aurelius
to Aristotle to Socrates you know those
are some of my my favorites
um you know the a Socratic discussion is
you pose a question and that question
you take a position whether you believe
that position or not you take that
position and then you defend and there's
some really clear guidelines about how
we're gonna you know I'm gonna be
respectful of that person's opinion I'm
gonna be respectful of the information
that they're going to present they're
going to have time to present that
information I can rebuke I can rebuttal
that information so it's like it's a
real clear format for us to debate you
know again something that we've lost and
forgotten how to do which is how to talk
to each other well under the socratic
model you and I could sit here and talk
about something that we totally disagree
on you know and we could do it
respectfully you know and and we have we
have four five six-year-olds doing it
every single day I mean I would call
that in my world philosophizing like my
one of my favorite things to do is just
philosophize or debate toe one end of
the line and let's vet this out all the
way let's let's let's like politely
respectfully and curiously vet things
out the the reason that we wrote Our
Republic in our constitution
um and in our Bill of Rights and our
formulation of government was to
encourage discourse right you have an
opinion I haven't been in we have two
these two separate parties you and I sit
down we debate and the better of the
ideas Rises to the top because of
conflict because of struggle because of
this discourse and that doesn't exist
right now because we're not able to talk
to each other because every because
everything is so divisive
um that's not the way it's supposed to
be the the way it's supposed to be is
you have an opinion I have an opinion we
sit down together there might be things
about my idea that's good there might be
some things about your idea that are
good do these things are these things
mutually exclusive not necessarily but
if we don't sit down and talk to each
other the the best idea might not be one
of our
um separate ideas but might be a new
idea that's built off of both of our
good ideas
that could never happen unless we're
able to sit down and have the socratic
conversation what's the history of red
blue you know all the things that create
so much divisiveness that nobody wants
to listen to the other one cognitive
dissonance around everything because of
identity politics or whatever all the
things are that people participate in
because it
I don't know maybe think they maybe
think it makes their life I think
they're being prideful in a way in their
mind but it really just is easier for
them you don't have to actually critical
critically think then
I I you've circled the drain around the
same thing where it's it's easier and a
lot of people just look for the easier
thing you know they're going to read the
headline and they're not going to read
um not even the article they're not even
going to look at the they're going to do
the research to understand the context
around it you know could you pick up
Hitler's Mein Kampf and be like hey
there's some good ideas in here yeah
yeah you could but guess what you should
probably read the context around it to
understand that this was a psychopathic
murder that then went on to genocide and
start the Holocaust right but if you
just picked up this thing and read it
was like huh I might even be able to
cure some diseases by this genetic
selection this is fascinating and now
we're so clickbaity we are so swipey we
are so headlining we are so like
divisively polarized and separated
intentionally this natural discourse
never occurs where I don't get to walk a
mile in your shoes I don't get to learn
about your ideas I don't get to even try
to be empathetic or sympathetic to want
to learn because I'm so
um I'm existing in this Echo chamber of
my own ideas whether like because I get
to select all the people that I follow
and all those people are aligned with my
beliefs and I I block and I silence and
I mute all the people that I don't want
to hear or I restrict or I don't even
know all the terms for all the different
social medias that do the same thing
which create an echo chamber for my own
ideas and in the Echo chamber my own
beliefs that just get magnified and
repeated back to me that solidify my
wrong ideas because my idea never met
against conflict or struggle of somebody
else's idea sure the algorithms lock you
in and then sell you on definitely
well they want so what are the greatest
barriers that someone needs to remove
from their habits and routines and their
life to this I feel like this could be a
blanket for everyone I feel like I feel
pretty open-minded but I think whatever
you tell me I'm gonna look at my life
and see if I can clear because
probably the worst thing someone could
do is think they're either they're
they're the most open-minded they don't
even need to try but so what so what are
those things that what are the barriers
of Entry to being more capable of having
real
not agreeable necessarily conversations
yeah I think first is you
um
and no no you personally but like I
gotta go yeah like look in the mirror
and and take that finger and point back
into you that first barrier usually is
going to be your own biases so how do
you identify your own biases it's find
conversations and people that make you
uncomfortable I'm never gonna do that in
front of somebody else unless I
familiarize myself with being
uncomfortable so I have to do things
intentionally I I have to self-elect to
do things that are uncomfortable so
maybe that might be cold water immersion
you know that might be sitting in the
sauna that might be a really really hard
workout that might be learning something
like ballet did you want to do ballet or
something yes no no I'm sure you're 100
right I did but I did ballet I I learned
no I did
um I uh the things that would blow your
mind the things that I chose to do I
have three daughters and one son and if
one of my daughters is like Dad will you
I absolutely without a moment of
hesitation figure skating yes if you
like this clip and you you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen